abone ol
[Alkış]
[Müzik]
e
herkese merhaba ben zaat Selam olacağım
ben de bizler bundan birkaç sene
öncesine kadar İstanbul'da güzel hatlara
sahip kendi iyi işlerde çalışırken yani
halimiz vaktimiz yerindeyken kurumsal
işlerimizden istifa edip daha sade ve
daha anlamlı bir hayatın peşine düştük
ve son iki yıldır da bu tecrübelerimizi
Bu mu yani at bir pot-k serisiyle başka
insanlarla paylaşıyoruz ama başlamadan
önce biraz meraktan bir soru sormak
istiyoruz okuduğum okul ya da yaptığı
meslek benim tercihimdi benim kendi
hayalimde diyenlerin ellerini görebilir
miyiz tabletinizi Çok fazla yok ama
mutlu olan insanlar dışarı çıkabilirler
bekleyebiliriz
Çünkü E geçen iki buçuk yılda şöyle
tepkiler çok aldık Sizinle ne kadar
keyfini çok yerindeydi düzenimi bozdu mu
falan gibi özel bir sorun olmak
istemiyoruz Okey devam ediyoruz
biz bu soruya Evet çok beğendi çok
sevmiyorum Çünkü bizim bu soruya cevabım
hayırdı benim en büyük hayalim sinema
okumaktı ya Daha doğrusu tek hayırlı bir
iş başka bir hayal bile kurmamış tıme
Ama şöyle bir problem vardı başarılı bir
öğrenciydim notlarımı yeni üniversiteye
giriş sınavında da yüksek bir puan aldım
Öyle olunca da ailem bana dedi ki Oğlum
Eğer gidip sanatı yönelir Sen
yeteneklerine bağlıdır ve sen de parasız
kalırsın eski Ben de onları dinledim
Çünkü insan ailesini kendisi için en
iyisini bileceğin düşünüyor En azından
bir yaşa kadar bir fakat sonra ben bu
şekilde
hayalim sinema okumak en gidip filmler
çekmekten gittim Finans eğitimi aldım
yetmedi üzerine bir de ekonomi Master
yaptım ve aklınıza gelecek en stabil
yaratıcılıktan en uzak meslek grubuna
dahil oldum yani bankacı olduk O
benim hikayem de bu sorunu çoğu insanlar
ya Türkiye'de çoğu insandan farksız
değildir bir lise Sondayım tercih dönemi
babam aradı dedi ki Oğlum endüstri
mühendisliği bölüm varmış duydun mu yok
dedim Baba duymadım dedi geleceğim
mesleğimiz kesin Araya bir yere yazalım
Tamam baba dedi yazalım Çünkü o zamanlar
diyorsun Telefonu erken kalkmak her
şeyden daha önemli böyle bir tercih
döneminden sonra ne oldu bilmediğim bir
bölüme girdim ve dört sene sonra artık
bende endüstri mühendisiydi maç
çıktıktan sonra herkesin bildiği bir
şirkette gibi çıktı satış yaptım ve o
sırada Türkiye'deki herkesin hayali olan
küçük tatlı bir kap işe başladım kendime
Beşiktaş'la bu Twitter kez atılıyor dur
okuyanlar Alice açtıktan sonra zamanda
fark ettim ki Benimle kahve ilgim var ne
hizmet sektörleri gün var hatta Kahveci
açmak benim hayalim bile değilmiş Bu
sadece bir hayalmiş Ve ben bunu dile
kalmışım E bunu fark ettikten sonra da
panik halinde O bildiğin sulara kurumsal
hayata koşarak geri döndüm Şimdi
olacağını asla çocukluk arkadaşız ama o
zamana kadar ok en yakın değiliz ama
konuşmaya başladı da Tam da bu dönemde
şunu fark ediyoruz ikimizde birebir aynı
şeyleri yaşıyoruz Yani ikimizde
ailemizin bizden beklentisini yine
getirmişiz İyi işlerimiz var
gelirlerimiz İyi bir statünüz varamam
mutlu değiliz yaptığımız işte bir tatmin
duygusu Bulamıyoruz hayatlarımızı bir
anlamı yokmuş gibi geliyor ve tüm bu
duygular içinde sıkıştı ımızın
hissediyoruz nasıl çıkacağımıza dair en
ufak bir fikrimiz bile yok ve o dönemde
artık bu işten sadece ikimizin
yaşadığından neredeyse Emin gibi Çünkü
sosyal medya girdiğimizde Herkesin
hayatı çok yolunda insanlar tarifler
ediyorlar tatillere çıkıyorlar
eğleniyorlar evleniyorlar bir de üzerine
bir su atla Sadece bizim dükkanda oturup
hayat hakkında konuşuyoruz Metin2 Okey
kesinlikle problem Biz de Herkesin
hayatı yolunda bize bir sorun var
bu ve işin en kötüsü de büyük ihtimal
Biz olarak sosyal medyada görsel Bizim
için de aynı şeyleri düşünürdünüz
Şimdi ben en son dayanamadım bu konuyu
dip babamı açmaya karar verdim Belki o
bana bir yol göster ben gittim Dedim ki
baba ben işimi sevmiyorum Babam da bana
dedi ki Oğlum istediğin zaten sevilmez
Şimdi ben Tabi babam da olduğu için
dediğine de koşulsuz inanıyorum Ondan da
bunu duyduktan sonra dedim ki eyvah yani
hayat dedim Meğer buymuş yani Sevmediğin
bir şeyi ömrünün sonuna kadar mutsuz bir
şekilde yapacaksın geldi bu düşünce ile
beraber ne kadar karamsar bir mahalle
ürünümüz tahmin edebilirsiniz
bize bu anlattığımız hikayesi birazcık
ve tanıdık geldiyse içinden bir parça
kendinden bulduysanız Bu yaşadığımız
Burhan'ın adı çeyrek Hayat krizi ve
gerçekten de dünyanın heryerinde
milyonlarca genç Bu yaşadığımız şeylerin
Birebir aynısını yaşıyorlar çok kısa
tanımlamak gerekirse çeyrek Hayat krizi
bir insanın genelde bir gencin hayatını
gittiği yöne ya da kalitesine dair
yaşadığı aktivite verilen bir isim
genelde 20 yaştan ortalarından sonra
ortaya çıkıyor Ve insanı yüzden eşek
yaşayacağı gibi garip tahminde bulunuyor
farkındayız işte biz de çeyrek herkesi
bizi bulduktan Allah bize bu sahibi
olacağına birbirimizi bulduktan sonra
tam olarak bu konular üzerine konuşmaya
başladık Ve konuştukça gördük ki aynı
yerde kaldığımız sürece aynı kısır
döngünün içine giriyorduk yani kariyer
basamaklarını istemediğimiz bir yönde
tırmanıyordu ve önümüze çıkan
fırsatlarda insanlar da gene bu alandan
oluyordu Ama bizim yapmak istediğim
şeyler tamamen bambaşkaydı Ve o an idrak
ettik ki bu kısır döngüyü kırmanın tek
yolu o güne kadar emek emek inşa
ettiğimiz her şeyi yerle bir etmekten
geçiyordu ve biz de bu düşünceyle bir
daha geri dönmemek üzere istifa etti ve
kurgusal hayallerinizi çöpe attık Şu an
ne düşündüğünüzü nü çoğu zaman
farkındayım çok karşılaştık Çünkü bu
çocuklar İstanbul'da yaşarken böyle
kafalarına göre istifa ettiklerine göre
en azından kenara para atmışlardır ya da
bu çocukların Ailesi parası vardı diye
düşünüyorsunuz yoktu o kadar yoktu ki bu
kadar hızdan sonra duvar İstanbul Kevin
kapattı İzmir'de annesinin yanına
taşındı ben de kendimi çıkışı bulana
kadar dönmemek üzere çok uzun süre
İstanbul'dan gittim ve bu süreçte
gerçekten daha bu ve birkaç aydır dahaki
daha uzun bir süre hayatımız gerçekten
minimum seviyelerde yaşadık
Ama şöyle güzel bir şey oldu Biz istifa
attıktan sonra daha çok okumak için daha
çok düşünmek için kendimizi daha iyi
anlamışım epey bir vakit bulduk ve bu
süreçte de olacağını varoluşsal
sohbetlerimiz giderek derinleşmeye
başladı Biz de en son da dedi ki biz bu
konuşmaları kayıt altına başkalarıyla
paylaşalım ve böylece de bu mi yani
doğmuş oldu botkis tadını bunu yani
koyduk Çünkü bu bize dayatılan anlam
veremediğimiz her şeye verdiğimiz
gerçekten en içten en samimi tepkiydi
abi Şöyle ki hayatımızı okul salonunda
geçiriyoruz sonra Maaşı iyi diye beyaz
sadece üniversiteden mezun olduk diye o
işi yapmaya devam ediyoruz herkese var
diye kredi çekip bir tane telefon satın
alıyoruz Yaşımız geldi diye evleniyoruz
ailemiz beklediği çocuk yapıyoruz E
zaten sonra emekli olup örüyoruz ve bu
mu yani İlk bölümümüzün adında
şaşırırsınız ki bu
[Alkış]
ve ilk bölümün adı da şaşırırsınız ki
çeyrek hepinizi
Biz bölüm paylaştığımızda Öyle bilinen
tanınan insanlar falan değil ama
paylaştıktan sonra bir gün içinde çok
enteresan bir şey oldu dilden dile ağzı
hazır yayılmaya başladı ve birkaç gün
içinde sosyal medyada defalarca kez
paylaşıldı yüzlerce mesaj aldık ve
birkaç gün içinde kendi Türkiye'nin en
çok dinlenen pop kesin arasında bulduk
ve gördük ki birçok insanla Aslında
bizimle aynı sebeplerden dolayı kendini
mutsuz ve sıkışmış hissediyorlar the ve
insanlar da tıpkı bizim gibi bu
dünyamıza kendini yaşadıklarını
inanmışlardı Şimdi siz büyük ihtimalle
insanlarda Böyle bizim gibi beyaz yakalı
İstanbul'dan tipler oldu düşünüyorsanız
Eğer çok feci yanılıyorsunuz Çünkü
içlerinde aklınıza gelebilecek her
meslek grubundan her yaştan her şehirde
insanlar vardı ev hanımları Kuaför
çırakları hemşireler Doktorlar avukatlar
yani gördük ki çeyrek Hayat krizine
herkes yaşayabiliyor a bu dünya tekinden
bir iki üç kişi istifa etti şeyi
öğrendik Hah
gerçek gerçek
bizim ilk bölümü paylaştığımız
zamanlarda dediğimiz gibi ben
Eskişehir'de annemin yanındaydım ve ne
olduğunu anlayamadık Bu yıl alışkın
değildir Çünkü annene gittin dedim ki
bizi Pocket kaybetmiştik paylaşmıştık
dün ve inanılmaz iyi gidiyor dedi ki
poke
sinepop kesin olun açıkladım Anneme ne
konuştunuz dedi Dedim ki ya Biz 66/4
merkezindeyiz ve zaten işlerimizden da
bu yüzden istifa etti Bunu konuştuk
dedim Annem hiç bu kadar çok güzelken
görmemiştim böyle araya girmeye
çalışıyor sus devam etme falan diyordu
eski yapmaya devam ediyor muşum gibi
bunu tabii ki art niyetle kötülük
yapmadım yüzüyor farkındayım ama zaten
tam olarak burada başlıyor onların
cenaze Onun için çeyrek Hayat kız gibi
şeyler tamamen uydurma zora gelmediğimiz
için uydurduğumuz gerçek olmayan şeyler
ve asla düşündüğümüz zaman da tam olarak
bu yüzden bu kadar gerçekler bizim o ilk
bölümümüzü yaptığımız günden bu yana iki
yıl geçti biz bu etrafını tam 80 bölümü
yaptık ve yaşadıklarımızdan
okuduklarımız dan konuştuklarımızı
öğrendik ki çeyrek Hayat krizi
hayatlarımızı eski kuşakların başarı
kalıplarına göre yaşamamızı bir sonucu
şimdi bize hayatımız boyunca öğretilen
Eğer başarılı olmak istiyorsan bu
kutuların hepsini sırayla Bir tık atman
gerektiğini fakat sonra biz gerçekten
hayata atıldı ve bu başarıları elde
etmeye başladık Ama gördük ki hayat
kutular Atik atmaktan ibaret değil bu
şekilde yaşayarak mutlu olmak da mümkün
değil zaten farkındaysanız bu kutuların
hiçbir içinde böyle mutlu olmak kendini
bulmak iz bırakmak gibi bireysel şeyler
yok Tam da bu yüzden de bu başarı
kriterleri bizi mutlu etme ihtimali yok
biz bu dönemde Veya bizim gibi insanlar
kim olduğumuz hakkında ve kim
olabileceğimiz hakkında çok fazla kafa
yorduk çok fazla kafa yoruyoruz e
dolayısıyla da basmakalıp herhangi bir
tane başarı kalıbının sıra mıza mümkün
değil tabi öte yandan da hadi diyelim ki
bir şekilde Bu başarı kalıpları
benimsedik ama bu elde etmek Öyle eskisi
kadar kolayda değil yani Artık yalnızca
diploma sahibi olmak meslek sahibi olmak
anlamına gelmiyor ev yada araba satın
almak birçoğunuzun uzak Bir hayalden
ibaret evlilik ve çocuk yapmanın
Hayalini bile kuramıyoruz ama diğer bir
yandan da çalışma saatlerimiz hiç
olmadığı kadar uzun başarı baskı hiç
olmadığı kadar yüksek ve tükenmişlik
hissi hiç olmadığı kadar yaygın eşitlik
başarıları elde etmek bu kadar zorken ve
deli de bu kadar ağır Ken Tüm bunları
gerçekten isteyip istemediğiniz ister
istemez sorgulamaya başlıyorsunuz Okey
tamam yeterince içimiz karardı görüyorum
böyle ellerini falan yan var Sonra
karşımıza anksiyeteden Şehit herkesin
doğumunu anladık okey O zaman artık daha
önemli kısma geçebiliriz bu kız nasıl
atacağız Biz kendi çeyrek askerlerimize
atlatırken üç tane temel nefes
geliştirdik size kısaca bunlardan
bahsetmek istiyoruz biz mutsuz olduğumuz
işleri yaparken Aslında yapmamız gereken
ne olduğunu çok iyi biliyorduk çok iyi
farkındaydık yani istifa etmemiz
gerekiyordu ama biz bunu yapmaktan bu
düşünce vardı Başkaları ne der istifa
ettiğimde gelirmi statümü kaybettiğimde
27 yaşında alemi evine taşındığında
başkaları bizim hakkımızda ne
düşünecektir Çünkü çevremizdeki insanlar
ne düşündüğünü o zamanlar şimdi de göre
çok daha fazla önem istiyordu kendimizi
sürekli akranlarını dışımızdaki ayıkıyon
kıyaslıyor duk Bence düşünürsen böyle
yapmamıza çok mantıklı yani düşünün çok
küçük yaşlardan itibaren sınavlarda
aldığımız puanlara göre derecelendirilir
yoruz Sonra da sınıflandırıyoruz sonra
eve gidiyoruz komşumuzun çocuğu ya da
bir akrabamızın çocuğun başarı
hikayelerini dinliyoruz iyi yılları bu
sistem içine geçirdiğiniz zamanda ister
istemez şöyle bir düşünce yapısı elde
ettik bizim kim olduğumuz kesinlikle
kendinizle ilgili değil çevremizle
ilgili bizim toksik düşüncelerden
ayrılmamız için şöyle küçük bir
aydınlanma yaşamımız gerekti farkettik
ki biz istifa ettikten sonra insanlar
Hakkınızda ne kadar kötü konuşurlarsa
konuşsunlar ne derlerse desinler
birkaç dakika sonra konu değişecekti bu
ve diğer konuşmaya başlayacaktı bizi
unutulacaktık ama biz yine günün sonunda
kendi hayatlarımızı başbaşa kalacaktık
ve bunu idrak ettiğimiz de de o hep
ertelediğimiz şey yaptık ve sonunda
istifa ettik Bu arada istifa ettikten
sonra ailemize dahil olmak üzere ne
kimse bize kötü bir şey söylediğini de o
tarz bir şey tam tersine Herkes gelip
bizi destekledi bize cesaret verdi Yani
biz insanların ne düşünce hakkında
düşünerek hayallerimizi kafamızı ki
şeyleri aylarca belki yıllarca boşver
etmişiz Şimdi biz istifa ettiğimiz
işlerimizi tamamen maddi nedenlerden
dolayı tercih etmiştik ama günlerimizi
yalnızca para kazanmak için bizim için
hiçbir anlam ifade etmek işlerle
geçirince ister istemez koca bir boşluk
duygusu olduğu için biz de gazda düşünce
o boşluk duygusu da olduğumuz kişiyle
olabileceğimiz kişi arasındaydı Yani
evet kendimizi geliştiriyoruz uk ama
bizim istediğimiz yönde bir gelişim
değildi bu benim hayalim hikâyelerle
insanlara ilham vermekti Oğulcan hayali
de sosyal sor bir şeyler yapıp başkaları
hayatına dokunabilmek TV bu süreçte
bizim en büyük eksiğimiz ve Aslında en
büyük ihtiyacımız olan şey bize yol
gösterecek bir insandı bu yani yaptıktan
sonra fark ettik ki ortaya çıkan şey
hayatta hep yapmak istediğimiz şeyle en
çok ihtiyaç duyduğumuz şeyin birleşimi
yani hikayelerimiz de insanların
hayatları dokunabildiğimiz onlara yol
gösteren bir Podcast insanlara
tecrübelerimiz binlerce insan hayatına
dokunup onları yolu gösterdikten sonra
fark ettik ki bu noktadan sonra geçmişte
yaşadığımız bütün sıkıntılar verdiğimiz
bütün yanlış kararlar kaybolmuş
hissettiğiniz bütün o zamanların artık
hepsi anlam kazanmaya başlamıştı o
dakikadan sonra bizim hayatımızda
yaşadığımız hiçbir şey boş yaşamamıştı
en başta da bahsettiğim
olmak istediğimiz kişiyle olduğumuz kişi
arasındaki boşlukla kapanmaya başladı
Çünkü biz Artık bizimle aynı zorluklar
yaşayan başka insanlar için bizim
yanımızda olamayan o insan olmaya
başlamıştık Peki sonra yaklaştığımız şu
dakikalar bu çıkıp desek ki
çeyrek Hayat krizi Aslında yeni bir şey
değil
ilçeye tat günü aslında yıllardır var
hayatımızda olan bir şey ama ismi
birazcık daha değişikti aklına birşey
gelen varmı orta yaş krizi
Aslında eskilerin başına kalıpları
onlara hayat boyu sonsuza kadar sürecek
ki mutluluk vermiyordu onlarda bizim
yaşadığımız sıkıntıları bu anketlere
değişiyor vardı ama bizden daha
geçiyorlardı bizden daha geç yaşamanın
verdiği dezavantaj da da bir şeyler
kökünden değiştirmek için çoğu zaman çok
geç kalmış oluyorlardı Yani aslında bu
açıdan baktığımızda çeyrek hayatı krizi
yalnızca vakitli bir orta yaş krizi Hani
Evet yine günün sonunda bir kriz ama en
azından
hala Yol yakınken hala bir şeyleri
değiştirmeye fırsatınız varken kapımızı
çalan bir kris ve Bizler bu krizi dibine
kadar yaşamış iki insan olarak şunu
söyleyebiliriz ki çeyrek Hayat krizi
başımıza gelen en güzel şey dedi bizim
için bir Uyanış ağrısıydı Eğer bu krizi
da olsak hala umutsuz olduğumuz
işlerimizi devam etmeye devam edip devam
ediyor olacaktık hayatlarımızı anlamlı
bir şekilde Bugün olduğu halde
değiştirilmiş olabilirdik ve bugün
burada sizlerin karşısında olmaya
bilirdik ve çeyrek etkinizi bize fark
ettik fark ettirdi ki hayat gerçekten
başkanın hayalini yaşamak için çok kısa
ve biz mutlu olabilmek için kendi
yolumuzu çizip insanlar Hayata dokunmak
zorundaydık
koymuyoruz bütün bu anlattıklarınız dan
sonra siz de çeyrek hayatı krizi
karşısında umutsuzluğa kapılmak yerine
onu ne kadar büyük bir fırsat olduğunu
görebilirsiniz ve umuyoruz ki siz de
çeyrek at krizi çeyrek ayak fırsatınız a
çevirebilirsiniz Teşekkürler abi